so up
do that side again
up is my injury and
oh
well i'm not going by him here
and then here
[Music]
first i enter then i'm going to expose
his back
here the doughnut comes straight down
where he was up
turn then i can get behind
oh now up and i passed him and then i
pull him
now i'm behind him now
up expose his back this way then you're
[Music]
behind
up then this is going to turn
off turn
which you can do at the yin spot
[Music]
okay so obviously he goes this is gonna
be a clash
so my first yin yang is up
okay
fast forward ahead so go ahead and do it
i come back here and you see i am
parallel to him
so when i start to rotate
i'm going to have to pull him so this i
grab a hold and i go here
and then i pull that is a clash two
it's just an inverse splash his energy
is going that way
and i'm gonna pull it so we don't want
that
next one clear boom i don't
i don't clash i kind of just move his
arm out of the way
like this but that won't take away the
second clash
and this is structurally inferior well
obviously
so what we're going to do instead is go
when the opening is
and as i rotate
expose his back boom you see
now when i do my entering
i'll be behind him here
so don't have your hands in
it leave
then step around him this way
so that the fight rotates
this is doable at the top so his energy
is going in and
i extend the yin and then as his yawn
comes
i let it go past me and the and his back
gets exposed
so don't move him this way
extend the yin up and then he finishes
and you let it go bye
that's what we're working on forget the
throw
it's this part follow it up let it go
okay once once i get past this
initial part and i get this to happen
now it comes the uh the
balance breaking part okay
so usually what we want to do is kind of
spin
him that's fine for a cooperative
bouquet
first cooperative aspect is that he
waits there
go ahead he's waiting there you see he's
waiting there
for me to do
second cooperative aspect is
that he's perfectly balanced
and this can be resisted resisting
of course i could overcome his
resistance but that is not
jujitsu hence it's not aikido
okay so what we're going to do is
he's going to finish his strike that
energy
is the only energy i have to work with
which is why
i can't have him weight and i don't want
him to wait
so just come up he's
going to finish this at an angle but i'm
going to
have his corner right here start to come
and stay still do you see like this
this is very much it is
like kokoho so he's going to come in
and i'm going to keep his head still i'm
just keeping his head still he
give me nugget from here okay
when i keep his head still though i'm
not going to do it
with reverse
i'm going to use the centripetal
energy of the tencon which will mimic
an anchor point on that head but it will
be a dynamic one
one that continually can continually
move
up the radius as he continues to lose
his balance
so he is here whoa like this
this is why i'm not pulling on this key
i just keep it going
this is also why the other arm can stay
in its guard position
and doesn't have to be used like this
so i read
and keep that thing ever so
on the positive the young side
of the centripetal energy which is going
to anchor
this point as it continues to go forward
okay that's what we're trying to do
now that i'm actually harmonizing yin
and young
and this hand can be doing something
else
the ten con is doing something else too
the ten con
is not a matter of me uh using
a kind of shot-putting technique to take
his balance
it's me just staying behind him in the
fight
it is staying with him though my tencon
is governed by him
and the ik adhesion that i have on my
hand here so for example
this is too close this is too far
i use my hand to measure where i'm going
to be
that's where i tank on
new point all this has to happen
incrementally
do not expect to do it all at once so
here nothing on him nothing on him
no you're in the other dreamland
everything is incrementally
boom and then same thing as he goes up
so he comes up i'm not here
jerking him or here and using the other
hand
as he comes up i'm using the same
adhesion
[Music]
so